des symboles qui chute de leur piédestal
littéralement à travers tous les états
unis depuis bientôt deux semaines on
abat on déboulonne ont repeint on t'a
goulon détruit les cibles des statuts de
personnages historiques divers accusé d'
esclavagisme ou de colonialisme comme
cette statue du général confédéré albert
pike à washington où ce buste de john
mcdonough à la nouvelle-orléans
propriétaires d'esclaves du 19e siècle
une purge des monuments statuaire qui
s'est même invité jusque devant la
maison blanche lundi dernier à
washington
des manifestants ont tenté d'abattre en
vain le bronze équestre d' andrew
jackson
connu pour son passé esclavagiste et la
déportation massive d'amérindiens
déboulonnage en règle qui ne sont pas du
goût de donald trump
au cours d'un meeting le président
américain a accusé la gauche radicale et
a promis des années de prison aux
auteurs de ces dégradations
mais la gauche radicale il déteste notre
histoire
il déteste nos valeurs et il déteste
tout ce que nous considérons comme
américains et nous avons raison et
certains ont été envoyés en prison et
d'autres iront en prison
non nous allons arrêter ça ne vous
inquiétez pas ne vous en faites pas dix
ans c'est long à passer en prison
des déclarations qui ne devraient guère
apaisé les tensions d'autant que la
communication du milliardaire ces
dernières semaines est particulièrement
clivante voire agressive au point de
forcer les réseaux sociaux à prendre des
mesures
il y à un mois déjà twitter avait
signalé une publication du président
américain pour apologie de la violence
ces voyous déshonore la mémoire de
georges floyd je viens de parler au
gouverneur tim wise et je lui ai dit que
l'armé est entièrement avec lui à la
moindre difficulté nous prendront le
contrôle
mais si les pillages commencent les tirs
commencent ce mardi donald trump a de
nouveau été sanctionné par la plate
forme cette fois pour comportement
inapproprié
il n'y aura jamais de zone autonome à
washington dc tant que je serai votre
président si l'essai ils seront
confrontés à une force
rieuse même facebook pourtant réticent à
se fâcher avec les maison blanche a dû
se résoudre à sévir en cause un message
publicitaire
la publication s'attaquait à la gauche
radicale et afficher un triangle rouge
inverser un symbole utilisé par les
nazis pour désigner les prisonniers
politiques dans les camps de
concentration
une communication maladroite de la part
du clan trump fragilisé par le mouvement
black like the matters et la crise
sanitaire
l'élection présidentielle elle doit se
tenir dans à peine plus de quatre mois